all of you have a decision to make
it has never happened in the history of
this country
an ex-president viciously attacking his
successor
trashing our commander-in-chief his
party
and all those americans who put him in
the oval office
this on the heels of an anonymous op-ed
piece
allegedly written by a gutless senior
administration official
or not and published in collusion
with the new york times a trump-hating
newspaper
there is so much hatred and resentment
over the success of this president
that they simply cannot handle it
i've got news for you it's not going to
stop
the haters aren't going anywhere but if
you're a patriot
and you like the course america is on
just ignore them get behind this
president and vote
yesterday with a full throttle savage
attack on the president
barack's message obstruct and resist
he pontificates about the reality of
racial discrimination
slavery and the quote darker aspects
of america's story accusing
president trump as follows
he's just capitalizing on resentments
that politicians
have been fanning for years
a fear and anger that's rooted in our
past
are you kidding if anyone
has stoked racial hatred and
divisiveness
it's you and your self-proclaimed
wingman attorney general eric holder
running off to ferguson
attacking all law enforcement whenever
there's a death even before
there's any investigation and in case
you don't remember barack
no cops were found to have committed
wrongdoing
in michael brown and freddie gray's
killings
you even stoke religious division are
you
serious you're the one who shows up at a
national prayer breakfast
in 2015 after the beheadings of
americans by isis
having the gall to tell christians to
get off their high horse
over atrocities committed in the name of
islam
in fact aren't you the same guy who in
and 2015 criticized christians
and working class voters in old
industrial towns
decimated by job losses saying we
christians cling to guns and religion
you call republicans elitist you're the
elitist
looking down on hard-working americans
and then you say but over the past few
decades the politics of division and
resentment
and paranoia has unfortunately found a
home
in the republican party
the politics of division has found a
home in the republican party
that's as ridiculous as saying that this
administration is cozying up to russia
you want to talk about cozying
this is my last selection yeah
[Music]
what were you talking about barack you
never
answered that question what would you
have more flexibility
on after the election was it the sale of
our uranium
was it the money you were going to send
to iran
was it meddling in our election was it
money to the clinton foundation
how about your foundation
your narrative of republicans as nazi
sympathizers
is a dog whistle to your base there is
no
truth to it but you insist on repeating
it to stoke up the hatred
by your base how hard can that be
saying that nazis are bad
maybe you want to say that to the
anti-far who claim to be anti-fascist
but they're all leftists from your party
and they
are the ones who want to suppress free
speech and would rather
burn down a building than hear what the
right has to say
that's fascism and you have the
unmitigated gall
to say that you return the economy to
healthy growth
and the longest streak of job creation
you don't mention numbers here because
there is nowhere to go but
up from the bottom and you say
we took out bin laden and wound down the
wars in iraq and combat role in
afghanistan
who do you think you are douglas
macarthur you couldn't make a military
decision for your
life you're the same guy whose feckless
foreign policy couldn't figure out what
to do with that jv
team isis whether to contain them
dismantle them or destroy them
none of which you did and you got iran
to halt
its nuclear program really
how would you know you didn't know
anything about the tans and forto and
iran as they were secretly spinning
centrifuges
lying to you and your gullible team
you didn't even require that we be
allowed to monitor their nuclear
development
you let out the worst of the terrorists
from gitmo
for a deserter that your standby liar
susan rice
bo bergdahl called him a hero
you ran the most corrupted
administration at least since harry
truman
and you can't stand it that every metric
under the trump administration is better
off
than when you were in office
and donald trump is one of the biggest
threats to our democracy
how dare you this man is the president
of the united states
someone that we put in office and he
is to be respected your attack on him as
a racist
and a fascist is not about making things
better for us
it's about you your ego and your corrupt
state
power structure you desperately tried to
defeat trump and it didn't work
and you remain in washington to support
the resistance
and obstruction of a sitting american
president while you stoke your racial
cop-hating narrative your version of
america
is not the america we want to us
social justice is about justice for
american citizens
and not illegal criminals to us
social justice is about taking care of
veterans
who come back to our shores with fewer
limbs
than when they left to us social justice
is not about burning our flag it is
about
raising it and lifting it
i'm sorry to say this but there is one
thing that you're going to have to live
with
the only reason that we have an outsider
businessman
president is because of you
your lies your policies and your
divisiveness
you barack you elected donald trump
and there's nothing you can do about the
fact
that he's sitting in the oval office now
so i guess i should say thank you barack
and that's my open